[MUSIC PLAYING]
And so when I went
and showed up,
I showed up actually
in the wrong lobby.
And I was waiting in it
for 20 minutes, thinking,
where is everybody?
Why is nobody here?
And then I get this frantic text
from one of the people saying,
oh, my god, where are you?
We're about to shoot the video.
And I started school and
I remember the first day,
I was so excited.
I got my notebook out
and my pencil bag,
and I had it on the table.
Because I thought I was going
to learn to read and write
that first day.
So I was just ready.
And then the whole day went by
and it was just introductions
and stuff like that.
And I was kind of sad
that it ended like that.
Because I thought I was going
to learn to read and write
the first day.
So your expectation was
just like, that's it,
you're going to be an adult, you
can do all these cool tricks.
Yeah, I'm going to
go to school and I'm
going to learn to
read and write.
And I was just so excited.
[MUSIC PLAYING]